hello and welcome to our show where I
interview people who have something to
say about the world today and how it's
changing they'll be from politics sport
business entertainment public life or
there'll be everyday people caught up in
the events of our times on this week's
show one of America's most senior
diplomats plus a mother seeking help and
answers after her daughter was killed in
a hit and run in Qatar
[Music]
deputy secretary of state Wendy Sherman
has worked under presidents Clinton
Obama and Biden she's been face to face
with Vladimir Putin and was a key voice
in the room during nuclear talks with
Iran we'll discuss the United States
hopes for an end to the war in Ukraine
fears that Tehran could be one step
closer to building a nuclear bomb and
Joe Biden's chances of re-election in
2024
also the victim of a hit and run and The
Grieving family who feel forgotten I'll
speak to the mother of Rafi sakanika who
was killed in Qatar in 2019. Joe
Sullivan her mum has been fighting for
answers from the Doha authorities ever
since her partner who helped build
stages for the World Cup lost his job
during their campaign they now want to
meet in with the foreign secretary
fast though 2023 is set to be a pivotal
year for the U.S and its diplomacy
President Joe Biden has suggested he
could meet with Vladimir Putin if the
Russian president is looking for a way
to end the war in Ukraine there's also
the possibility of a presidential visit
to Northern Ireland but could that trip
be overshadowed by ongoing tensions
between Britain and the EU over brexit
that's where I started my conversation
with the U.S deputy secretary of state
Wendy Sherman
Madam deputy secretary thank you for
being on Sky News for this uh trip to
other parts of Europe as well I wanted
to start off by asking you about
something that matters to us Brits and
also to the Americans next year we'll
mark the 25th anniversary of the Good
Friday agreement the president's due to
visit potentially Northern Ireland to
mark that moment how important is it
that the Northern Ireland protocol issue
is resolved by then I think we all want
to see the issue resolved President
Biden spoke with your new prime minister
and I think we all have optimism that an
agreement can be reached it's very
important from an American perspective
to reach an agreement and I think people
are working very hard to get there it's
terribly important and
back then then President Bill Clinton
who you know well uh closely was closely
involved in those negotiations to keep
talks going does President Biden stand
ready to get involved in the same way of
necessary I think America's always ready
to support the United Kingdom you know
we have a special relationship there's
no denying that I've started this trip
to the capitals of Europe and I began in
London
this is an incredibly Rich relationship
now we're sorry that we are not in the
final games of the football match and I
did mean to start by congratulating
England on its win against Senegal and
now coming into the finals I know it'll
be quite a match on Saturday and I can
tell you that Americans are now as we
say Soccer Crazy uh football crazy so
we'll be watching uh with eager eager
interest and I should say the USA for
surveillance fights as well and got
through to the qualifying stages getting
knocked out the other night but I have
to ask you now you've mentioned it on
the special relationship France versus
England who would you like to win
um whoever comes out first uh I think
it's going to be a tough match we were
very excited to get into the final
rounds and we have a young team I think
they'll come back the next time even
stronger and you know I had an event at
the state department on our eighth floor
which is our big rooms I even had a
soccer jersey that the U.S soccer team
gave me said Sherman won we invited all
the Diplomatic Corps at big screen TVs
there is just football Madness in the
United States as there is around the
world because I think Sports brings
people together so we're very excited to
watch on so it's a very diplomats can't
because you're of course going to Paris
next so
so maybe wise not to come out in favor
of England but my oscar afterwards
President Biden said last week he was
prepared to speak to Mr said if in fact
there was an interest in him deciding
he's looking for a way to end the war in
Ukraine he hasn't done that yet he went
on to say the only way for that to
happen would be for President Putin to
pull out of Ukraine number one what does
pull out mean does it mean the
withdrawal to from Crimea
I think that we have always said nothing
about Ukraine without Ukraine and the
United States and the United Kingdom
Great Britain have been side by side in
this effort
I'm really just so grateful for
everything that Britain has done to
support the ukrainians America as well
53 billion dollars to date in our
security assistance and additional
humanitarian support
so we have a lot ahead of us and what's
important here is there is one aggressor
and that's Vladimir Putin and one victim
and that's Ukraine we've seen the
ukrainians will not be victims they're
going to fight for their country and
it's why we all support them in every
way we possibly can I think there's
tremendous support here and there's
tremendous support in America to get to
the end here this can end
if Vladimir Putin pulls his troops out
but Deputy is actually just quickly to
follow up on that
um president zielinski's made it really
clear that territorial integrity means
Crimea which was annexed in 2014 being
returned to Ukraine just because the U.S
would support that we support President
zolensky we support the Ukrainian people
it's not for us to decide what any
negotiated solution would be at the end
it is really up to the ukrainians do you
see the war ended next year are you
hopeful for that I'm hopeful the war
ends as quickly as possible I think
everybody does I think Ukrainian people
want the war to end they are the ones
who have suffered so enormously just
imagine the loss of life the loss of
infrastructure the loss of whole
Villages and towns and cities and Dr
it's actually if Putin isn't scary
enough Iran's nuclear Ambitions continue
to grow you negotiated the Euro Iran you
can deal on under President Obama
President Biden promised to revive it it
hasn't happened instead Iran has
enriched more uranium than ever before
and elected a hard-line new president is
now is Iran closer to a nuclear bomb
than it's ever been
we're in a very tough Place The Joint
comprehensive plan of action is still on
the table but it's unfortunately not on
the agenda right now because one the
Iranians really did not take the very
good deal that was on the table
negotiated by the P3 by the Europeans
with the United States in another hotel
during it and indeed we've seen a
protest in Iran we have seen Iran give
uavs to Russia to prosecute this
unprovoked and premeditated invasion of
a sovereign country Ukraine so there is
a lot going on right now we also have
detained Americans who are wrongfully
detained in Iran that we are trying to
get home to their families a lot going
on here
what about the regime we've had
widespread reports we've seen it about
protests and brutal repression
diplomatic sources are telling Sky News
they believe the regime is finished it's
just a question of time before it goes
is that your reading of the situation
too I really am the situation is
certainly that the people of Iran have
said they have had enough
that they want a different way forward
that is for them to decide not for
Outsiders to decide we want to support
those who are protesting in every way we
can so that they can make their own
choice about their own future and just
finally the special relationship the
British prime minister made a foreign
policy speech last week and said nothing
about the special relationship isn't it
the truth that when the British prime
minister who normally likes to trumpet
this forgets to mention the special
relationship then it's probably a
concept that's had its day now what I
think it says is we are who we are with
each other here we do not need to
continue to name it even though I've
mentioned it today because it just is we
are have such a deep history with each
other we have such a an alliance with
each other and you know when President
Biden became president one of the things
he said he was going to do was really
put a focus on alliances and
Partnerships because nothing in this
world can be done by yourself even if
America leads On Any Given issue we
cannot do it alone we will always be
doing it with others and we will always
have Great Britain with us side by side
hand in hand just quickly is it easier
with the new prime minister rushi sunak
than it was with Boris Johnson or Liz
trust for President Biden we are very
delighted to have your prime minister
and look forward to working with him
he's just getting started we have a lot
of good work we're going to do ahead now
we're complete now so I'm going to push
my luck if I made one final question
Donald Trump is run in 2024
can President Biden really repel that
challenge and push on into a second term
when he will be in his mid-80s well
that'll be a decision that President
Biden will make and the American people
will ultimately decide on the president
I work for President Biden I'm a strong
supporter of his I will say that if you
look at our midterm election you will
see that a lot of folks who had denied
the outcome of our last election lost so
I think the American people are speaking
about the kind of future they want and I
was in Mexico City the day after our
election everybody asked me what I
thought about the winners and losers and
I said the winner was democracy
democracy won on our election day
because we had a smooth free open
transparent and solid election you'd
like him to run though I get I'm
gathering you'd like him
okay
thank you so much thank you so much for
joining us on Sky News today thank you
thank you
three years ago Joe Sullivan experienced
every parent's worst nightmare when her
daughter Rafi failed to come home after
a night out it transpired Rafi have been
killed in a hit and run by a man driving
almost
120 miles an hour afterwards there was
no knock on the door from the police Joe
only discovered her daughter's death
after searching hospitals and eventually
a mortuary her killer was eventually
brought before the courts and given a
sentence of two months in prison
this week a UK coroner criticized the
Qatari authorities for not cooperating
with his investigation he apologized to
the family citing a lack of evidence and
said he could not rule that Rafi was
unlawfully killed
Joe thanks so much for coming to talk to
us today and telling us the story about
your daughter Rafi
before we get into what happened
I'd first like to get your reaction to
the inquest verdict the coroner was
hugely sympathetic with your case but
had to conclude on the evidence that he
had that Rafi was the victim of a road
traffic accident and not the victim of
an unlawful killing what's your reaction
to that
um so yes it was disappointing but we
completely understand
the decision he had to come to me he had
very limited information to go on so
it was kind of almost expected really do
you feel very angry though at the
failure
of the Qatari authorities to provide
information and assistance to help that
coroner that is you said
there was not really much else he could
do but to come to that verdict yes
they've had many an opportunity
we've approached them continuously our
advisor radziger has approached them
um the coroner has contacted the Qatari
authorities for information and they've
completely ignored everybody and rad
who's your your lawyer he he's written
to the foreign secretary today what
what's he said and what what are you
asking them for do you want a meeting
he's calling for a meeting with the fcdo
and
James cleverley to reopen this we we
want more information that we know that
qataris have and the foreign office told
us Joe that they'd offered supports in
the aftermath of rafi's death and that
they raised her case with the Qatari
authorities at a senior level is that
your experience do you know any
conversations took place so it was a
very minimal uh they were basically
pushed and forced to to ask for
questions
um we still don't know to this day
whether
mubarakal hazri has served his pitiful
two-month sentence in one uh
communication we were told yes he has
and then a week later we were told he
hadn't so we still don't have any
answers and that was the man that was
driving the car that hit hit rafi's car
yeah I want to go back to the beginning
if I may and
um Rapha your daughter and you've
described her as your best friend yeah
so you're very very close very close and
we've got some footage that you sent in
actually which I think we can see with
of you two dancing together at home in
Qatar there you are
um it's it's it's lovely to sit but it
must be hard to see it or work as well
um that was our apartment in Qatar
and you spent a lot of time together you
were very close and you did a lot of
dancing dancing singing laughing she'd
find something funny and everything you
and your family
are originally from there you are in the
car we're singing to Sean Paul
are you doing a bit of carpool karaoke
there yeah we loved it she knew all the
words and I just
make the noises she looks like a she
looks like she is full she is brimming
with life and having fun right
she's just an asset to the world
everybody loved her thank you for
sharing those videos and showing us Rafi
you clearly are very close
mum and daughter unit if we can let's go
back to the 30th of March 2019 that's
the day your life changed forever and it
was just a normal it was just a normal
day for you what were you and Rafi doing
that day
um so we had friends around for dinner
it's the 29th and evening we had friends
around for dinner
and rafid already arranged to go out
with a friend for coffee so she left us
about 7 30 she
said she wouldn't be late because we
were going we had like several buses
going Carmel racing the next day and she
was going to help me so she knew she had
to be back and be up early
so she left
um friends left and I went to bed and um
the morning came and it was about seven
o'clock I sat there and I thought I'll
wake her up in about an hour and as we
as was usual I always woke her up with
music so I'd walk in playing my phone
just dancing along and you know that's
how we'd start our day bike yeah exactly
so instead of saying come on let's go
I'd sort of she loved what Jimmy does
and we'd just be silly with each other
and so I was playing this music I opened
the door and her bed was not touched I
thought that's very strange she's either
got up and left or I'm not really sure
what's happened
so I started calling her phone no reply
continuously calling a phone and I said
to Dawn have you seen RAF he hadn't seen
her
so
um it got to about
nine o'clock I started calling all of
her friends I knew I said have you seen
Ralph no I haven't seen Ralph so yeah
you're now
in quite a panic I I yeah and I said too
Don I said we need to go to the police
um I can't see you know what
you know what what could have happened
so
I um
sorry
so we went to the police and uh
walked in and they said um you know sit
down you know what's the problem so lost
my daughter here's a copy of her
passport on my phone is a photograph
sit down so I'd sit down wait wait half
an hour then mumbling to each other
um half an hour goes by I said look can
you tell us what we need to do you know
I don't know where she is
um this touring and throwing went on for
a best part of three or four hours we
waited there until about probably about
four o'clock so we'd been there a good
six six and a half hours getting nowhere
and I just turned it on and I said I
think we need to go and go to the
hospital I think we need to go and start
exploring ourselves because they're
obviously not going to help us
they either know something or they you
know they're completely incompetent so
then you leave the police station then
you start going so the cities we go to
Hamad Hospital
and
um walk to the front desk and I said you
know we're looking for this person I
have a photograph of her passport on my
phone
so we're looking for this person the
lady shrugs her shoulders and kind of
points me to accident and emergency
and so we walked a little bit further
back and there was a doctor who just
taken over that shift
and I said look can you help us please
we're trying to find somebody I don't
know where we're supposed to go the lady
on reception isn't helping she may or
may not be in this hospital but the
police can't help me and he was you know
a very kind doctor and he allowed us to
look through
so he allowed us to look through the um
entry log
and it various names of people and then
it had
a one entry it said one female
unknown
DOA and then it was
um one
20 a.m something like that my husband
remembers the right time
and uh so I said what what does DOA mean
and he said it's Dead on Arrival
a nice I thought no that that just can't
be her I mean everybody she had a
passport with her you wouldn't be an
unknown female
we you know we had our um all sorts of
means of communicating with her and you
know it wouldn't be an unknown person
um so
after having kind of exhausted
everything there I said well I feel the
only thing I'm going to do is I'm going
to walk around the hospital myself
because if it's not an emergency entry
then it's possibly you know she's broken
her leg or something I'm not really sure
so I'm gonna walk and I walked all the
way around the hospital literally
peeling sheets so I'm really sorry I'm
looking for my daughter have you seen
this person have you seen this person
that was probably about two hours of
walking around yeah around myself and my
husband we were just walking around
going I'm really sorry I'm really sorry
uh nobody had seen her
um and then we we sat in the reception
going okay well what do we do now and we
both looked at each other and went
let's eliminate that entry in the book
um and and then we'll go home and then
figure out what our next plan of action
is so um
we walked to the mortuary
um I opened the door and there was a
doctor writing in the book and she had a
photocopy of my daughter's passport next
to her
goodness
and uh I I just started panicking I said
why why have you got my daughter's why
have you got a photograph of my
daughter's passport
and uh I I I've repeated this so many
times that I've never seen somebody so
cold and dismissive in my life she kind
of looked up and said
Brittanya you know British in Arabic and
I said yes and
indicated to the steel drawers and said
you know you want to see
and uh
sorry I'll try out
and so she walked us over to the
steel drawers just opened
draw out
okay you'll back the plastic
and there's
my daughter's body
all injured
stop completely unprepared for this
and um sorry I'm so sorry I'm completely
unprepared for this and I I didn't get
you know any amount of compassion
whatsoever neither of us know what to do
at this point we both Frozen
um
and I'm
you know I don't know whether I fell
down I don't know what I did I just the
whole world started spinning
and
I'm looking at wrath I started stroking
her head
and I kept saying my mother should go
through this
um
so um
we kind of looked her and she kind of
went here's paper
I know what we're supposed to do with
that
go to the police and collect her things
it was unbelievably
cold
oh Joe I'm so sorry
[Music]
um
and that and that's the beginning of a
three and a half year merry-go-rounder
we've been no answers
when did it become clear to you that
they were not investigating fully or
competently what had happened to Rafi on
that night
immediately right
because there's cameras on every single
corner of every street in Doha and Qatar
so they know exactly what's going on
everywhere and then what happened
with the man that was driving the car
that that struck
Rafi it took a long time for the
prosecutors to go after this person
so he was eventually convicted of
fleeing the scene causing death
dangerous driving and was given
two months which we have no evidence
that he's ever done and I think it was
just paying I think they just wanted to
blockade us and just go well you know
okay we've done something for you now go
away so he he was given two months you
have no idea whether he even served that
uh how did you feel when that verdict
was announced it pulled appalled he was
driving 120 miles an hour
um and then he fled the scene and fled
the scene but they have a two-tier legal
system there's one for qataris and one
for everybody else now had that been a
foreign National he had been locked up
immediately and Joe
what does the experience of what
you had you had your experience in the
aftermath of rafi's death
tell you about Qatari Society
you you were happy there and then
obviously after this happened I can't
stay there I can't be here yeah
so I saw a very ugly side to the place
very ugly
um
you you get kind of undercurrents of you
know behave and you know you're welcome
here if you say anything out of place or
if you criticize the government or if
you could criticize their mayor then you
are definitely in trouble so I always
was aware of the fact that we had to
respect the country and I always did
um but then once this happened
um we saw a completely different side to
the place
and
now billions of us what you know around
the world are watching the World Cup and
we're seeing Qatar host that World Cup
it's a huge moment for the country when
you see British sports and icons like
David Beckham promoting Qatar or perhaps
trying to put a gloss on the country's
image
what do you think of what do you think
how does it make you feel
it's all about money
all these people paid Qatar buys
everything it wants including people
so
people name their price and they go out
there and they do what they're told and
that's you know a lot of expats are
being paid quite well and won't speak
there as well because it is all about
Money Money Talks if anyone watching
this tonight is thinking of visiting the
country to see it for themselves what
would what would your advice to them be
so many people do go and visit and
nothing happens to them but you do need
to be aware of certain things that as
somebody who's lived in the country a
new her way around for us not to be able
to get
any justice or any form of closure then
I have no idea how anybody visiting
would ever be able to get any support
um
so go there with your eyes wide open
uh
yeah I think you know that we've come to
a time in our Evolution where we need to
kind of
call these people to account and go no
we're not we're not going to tolerate
this you know you can't do this to
people anymore that's you know we're in
2022
they're not in the medieval area where
we go around doing what we want to
people everybody's accountable for their
actions
and you can't put on a world event like
the World Cup and then expect you know
people to be treated so appallingly okay
thank you Joe thank you I know it's not
easy thanks for talking to us thank you
thank you thank you very much
Joe's story there while we did reach out
to the Qatari government and the Qatar
Embassy in London to get their view on
the case but they did not respond
the foreign office however told us we
have provided support to the family of a
woman who died in Qatar in 2019 and
raised her case with the Qatari
authorities at a senior level We Stand
ready to offer further Consular
assistance as appropriate
well thank you to Joe for sharing the
story and her memories of her daughter
Rafi and also to my first guest Wendy
Sherman
and if you scan this QR code on screen
right now you can watch all of our
interviews online and all of the
previous episodes of the show and you
can listen to the Beth Rigby interviews
podcast by scanning that QR code on your
screen right now and new episodes
available each week as I take a look at
the highlights of the interviews and
there's a few extra bits and pieces in
it too that's on the Sky News app or
wherever you get your podcasts
well that's all for this week's show
thank you as ever for watching
[Music]